this makeup oh sorry my titties are
sweating so bad I am actually a really
big fan of Lena Simone she went through
hell and back for for being a darker
skinned black woman she really channeled
all of that into her music and just her
word just listening to her words outside
of the music itself is poetry
I'm super concerned I don't know that
she has the spirit to do this and I
haven't watched the trailer for that
same reason cuz I was gonna be upset as
soon as I saw it although I love Zoey
and I do love Nina I am not too keen on
this matchup all right I'm gonna be
optimistic let's just let's see what
happens
okay she's singing is she really saying
I didn't know she could sing so
basically this is her after she's like
fallen from glory I like that the her
hair textures look natural and all of
that this makeup I think what's also
really hard about this is the
juxtaposition of the black guy that they
have that's the lead because you can
just see the richness and the realness
of his tone and then in comparison to
her she just looks so fake I feel like
his David kissed her
something like her whole face would come
off or something I just wonder what what
this is on her face that made it so dark
I am so distracted by how greasy she
looks I feel like this is just really
disrespectful I think that this sounds
like her to be honest
she sounds like Columbiana in blackface
there's all these quotes words like you
know she fought for her music and I'm
just like she also fought for her image
this is making me really sad
so did I just watch just know I don't
know how to say no in so many ways but
it just felt wrong and it was wrong a
lot of the crazy that we see in the
trailer and she's like throwing things a
lot of the anger was because she was
this darker skinned woman this is just a
general disappointment you know I'm
getting so emotional I'm sorry do not
get me wrong I think Zoe Saldana is a
great actress but nobody's gonna be able
to focus on how great of an actor she is
in this movie if she's in blackface I
never think that in this day and age
that I would have to look at something
like this you can get someone who's that
skin tone who is a good address but I
also think that putting all the blame on
her is too easy
be mad at Julia if you want to but I
definitely think that we as a collective
need to start questioning Hollywood we
need to start questioning places like
RLJ entertainment they
should have asked someone they should
have consulted Nina Simone's family what
does it say about my place in the world
as a black female if the roles that are
made for me the stories you want to tell
are about me and I can't even play them
I get a panel of black Twitter and they
can tell you if it's okay or not